this one's gonna be a weird one for me
and you know how many or some bleep you
don't know now you know your life is
different now appropriate that I'm
wearing some Miss cracker merch right
now because I'm gonna do another drag
queen makeup recruit grace chin I don't
like that title but I'm gonna stand by
it
I've done this a couple times in the
past and it has yielded terrible results
I'm fueled by failure yeah I went on
Twitter and asked you guys what drag
queen Luke should I try to recruit grace
and I immediately got a response from
Chester see who was on this season of
RuPaul's Drag Race and got made into
Miss cookie I miss cracker and he wanted
me to try to recreate his look from this
season on myself and then a lot about
this of you wanted me to also do that so
today I'm gonna try and turn myself in
to miss cookie which is [ __ ] up on so
many levels this is gonna feel
uncomfortable but that's the
entertainment value I'm gonna turn
myself into my ex-boyfriends Red Queen
makeover
after yeah why not that's sure I didn't
see any tutorials for this but I also
did not look because I just wanted to
kind of go on some image or images and
see if I can figure it out for myself
I've gathered some photos the look that
I will be trying to recreate to be fair
i watch this episode I was very proud of
Chester I was very proud of Miss cracker
[Music]
why not try to recreate this this is
gonna be so weird you're 32 years old
this is absolutely what you should be
doing for your job let the chaos and
anxiety begin oh hi so I have some
makeup on from earlier today that I
think I'll trying to take some of it off
yeah 5 oh hi goose join me hi she wants
to be part of the program to watch the
episode too
I've made my decision my god do I start
with I so sorry skin there's a lot going
on let's start with foundation the thing
that I just took off of my face let's
put foundation all over this face and
look pretty much exactly like we looked
like ten seconds ago I'm gonna cover my
eyebrows a little bit it doesn't do
anything let's put more on because I'm
gonna funfetti cake this face think I my
dad does not watch my YouTube channels
because he wouldn't even know what they
should do with any of this we painted
the barn put some under eye concealer on
oh I look like a subtle my first step is
kind of done we got the eyes are the
major part here it's very Courtney
Stodden I need to figure out how to do
these guys no that's not correct look at
this no this is so bad okay we got it
together so we're just gonna put a bunch
of white eyeshadow i'm gonna use candy
johnson's whipped cream eyeshadow oh
it's all a base i'm all about the base
both of mather a massage getting in the
tear ducts cuz we want to look away we
want to be whoa wow this look is all
about no things in moderation really
piling it on like the layers of
psychological weirdness that this video
might invoke oh this is very like guy
from powder goes to erase basically it
looks like he's got some like purpley
cut crease thing that goes up a black
eyeliner all roughly where to cut crease
situation if that's even what this is it
might not even be a cut crease it might
just be a beautiful drag look and I
don't know what I'm talking about
where's my eyeliner it's just fully
smashed in do you like my eyeliner and
smash that subscribe button all right
Justin we just have a better nose than
me dammit I already use a black eyeliner
and draw on some exaggerated winged
eyeliner to kind of connect out here
they're gonna put some eyeshadow over
and see what happens
okay that's a little sloppy but we'll
clean that up so now I'm just gonna take
like a fluffy brush and try and like
soften the edges of this this is totally
fine he's got some purple kind of up
here too let's see what we can do I have
some Purple's in the Mundy interstellar
palette and I got some Pink's in my
candy Johnson I'm sorry for everything
just don't have it's pigmented a pink
that's the only reason this isn't
working
Wow okay let's put some exaggerated
black liquid liner I am he obviously has
drawn on eyebrows I'm not committed to
the glue down fake eyebrow game because
it's not worth it so instead I'm gonna
see if I can put some more foundation on
my eyebrows and see what happens if I
try to draw over that wait while those
dry I'm gonna do some black liner under
the eye picks and draw on some
exaggerated eyebrow let's see what
happens
[Music]
oh this is very black swuan Oh yikes Tom
sash Oh get rid of the Wi-Fi let's start
doing some contouring we're gonna start
with some nose contouring i'm gonna use
my shade and light palette from Kat Von
D already way too much oh hi let's do
some contour the cheap little bit like
The Tin Man who's this audibly groaning
I'm with you let's put some lashes on
those can cover up any mistakes bombings
are now lashes okay here's progress
report it's just a slop vest from a
distance doesn't look that bad up close
yikes I love this is the core notes of
bad mother [ __ ] Oh too bad a cop it look
more like Chester C's fake eyelashes cuz
putting on my lashes takes a second it
gives you a girl moment to pause and
thinking about what you're doing
unfortunately my lashes are sort of on
and I go
look at myself in a different mirror and
it made me want to fix some things I've
done and just take some time to do some
quick little I gotta fix this [ __ ] so
give me a second put some gloss on top
if I shine Urban Decay savage this one's
called
oh yeah this is the Barbie pink we all
know this well there's only one final
touch that I think is gonna complete
this whole totally successful look give
me a second yeah direct I like to window
my house where I can see the Sun setting
if it's like honestly just truly
beautiful and then I look at the view
pioneer mega-haul its offsets that
you've been replaced portal in here take
a look Wow Wow mm-hmm are you getting
this cookie vibes Keebler elves vibes Oh
- let me see if I can recreate the poses
[Music]
this is so weird well miss cookie I hope
I did you proud let me know in the
comments and below how you think I did
recruit grace like this let me know if
there are other looks that you think oh
look that Sun lights hitting me now oh
okay I guess that this is just so many
layers of weird let me know in the
comments below what other looks
Luke's etc that you think that I should
try to recruit grace imitation is the
highest form of flattery and just don't
look anything like the art you made so
I'm so sorry other than that I don't
know you know the world is real sucked
up in a lot of ways right now and so I
think for everyone's mental health it's
important to find ways in which you can
kind of get some space from the tree and
just create some joy in your life this
is how I'm doing it